when i say consistency it's coming in
and doing the same actions inside your
site again sounds really
like similar and easy but so many times
i've been
with consultants where they've had a
superb month they've got this massive
commission check at the end of the month
and the next month they're just
not the races they're not coming back
and not following the same actions the
consistency is actually the actual
the actual um work you put in um
throughout the course and i said the
inputs if you do the same amount of
inputs
on most months the outputs will be
what the inputs dictated so it was
listed of like quality
quality consultants the dna was go
harder and faster than
anyone else in the early days it kind of
felt like we were
we were kind of taking on the world um
and this is when i joined with 10 people
be just based in bristol
um and as the as the company grew
we just managed to attract some
something some of the promotions
were because we were we were growing at
such a rapid rate i was kind of almost
thrust into those positions because
there was probably no one better at the
time
and truth be told i probably wasn't
ready for a lot of them